[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
but as we start to understand our power
we discover there are others both paid a
heavier price
[Music]
you
many threats stand between us and the
source of the signal those of us who
survived exposure to the anomaly
move beyond our physical limits we've
become altered as pyromancers we
manipulate explosive volcanic energy and
devastating walls of flame
as tricksters we manipulate the fabric
of time and space to take out enemies
devastators we shatter the earth around
a brute force powered by the planet
and so our journey across Enoch begins
to discover what lies at the heart of
the signal
you
[Music]
[Music]
we came to Enoch looking for hope a
fresh start on an untouched planet
then we found the signal so we set out
to discover
that was our first encounter with when
the storm struck the outriders are
forced back into cryo sleep
thirty years later when we finally woke
the world had changed but so a week
signal is still out there
and at its source
chance to find answers
just start again
hello again my name is Lucy and this is
the outriders broadcast our monthly show
in which we delve into the nitty-gritty
of our co-op RPG shooter and surface the
staggering depth the game has to offer
last month in the series debut he took a
look at law UI and world tears in a show
we called built for the core we showed
you some brand new areas of the game and
also a huge deep dive into the trickster
class in the first of our live videos
today we are focusing a little more on
story the planet of Enoch where the
events of the game unfold and the cast
of characters that will join the
outriders in their search for the source
of this signal story is pretty
importance in outriders and there's a
lot of it in telling the dark and
desperate sci-fi story at the heart of
the game there's an hour and a half of
performance captured cutscene with your
outrider and all of your customization
and gear front and center of the action
there's also two hours of additional
cutscene that flashes out the side
missions and extra Story contents of the
main path but how does it all fit
together how do you navigate the world
and all that it has to offer
well let's take a look at that now shall
we as we jump into the game itself and
share with you what's involved moments a
moment as you explore and survive Enoch
all right Sven over to you
outriders is massive both in terms of
game length and the numbers of hours
you'd be able to pour into it and a
physical distance you'll traverse over
the course of the story so today we're
excited to show you more of the journey
and structure of outriders how will you
move about the game and how the various
features systems and story all come
together in last month's broadcast we
explore the first city the area of Enoch
first settled by the refugees of Earth
everything from the section of the game
unfolded here in this area of the map
the first city sits within a larger area
of colonized Enoch which you can see
here here humans have made a life as
best as they can and build cities
strongholds factories and mines as they
try to survive this is where the
outriders are firstly awoken from
cryosleep
and where first hours in the game are
spent humanity has always struggled to
leave this place with the raging a
normally storms and monsters preventing
further colonization of the planet
pushing society back to the dark ages as
you will see though there's a whole lot
more to Enoch as an outrider you're one
of the few powerful enough to leave
humanity's broken settlements and
journey out across this hostile planet
but what does it mean in actuality
outriders takes advantage of a hopping
spoke structure connecting busy settled
areas the hubs with combat arenas in
free roam areas the spokes the main
story missions push you through the game
and a large number of side quests and
additional content can be discovered on
or off the beaten path a side quest
scale to your level so do the rewards it
means even early side quests can be
meaningful played late in the game and
it's we're saying side quests aren't
fluffy objectives that take place in the
same place pace as you've experienced in
the main
their new bespoke areas of Enoch that
you could miss entirely and they often
reveal more secrets about the world in
lore let's travel quickly to Eagle peaks
snow-capped mountains that encased a war
zone to take on a side quest there this
your whole company there used to be more
of us something happens to the men up in
these hills we hear voices some leave
and don't come back same for anyone who
goes looking for them
maybe an altar could have more luck in
finding them could you lend a hand
all right let's play detective if I was
a missing soldier wandering off into the
night hearing voices so it seems the
last remaining survivor of our missing
soldiers was just sacrificed to the
anomaly we need have some words with
this deadly cult in its leader
[Music]
we're only giving you a small taste of
this little side adventure it takes a
fair bit longer to make our way into the
inner chambers here and as always we
like to keep some surprises for you but
it's time now for an epic showdown with
the altered cultists leader
seems you had yourself a little cult
brewing up here I don't know this place
seems to make people flip their [ __ ]
lids yeah nice by completing the side
quest we can now choose a sweet piece of
new gear as a reward but that's sorted
let's talk a little bit more about hops
in hops your weapons are holster for a
time and you can soak in a bit of life
Oh neato here you can visit vendors to
sales grab and purchase gear freaking
bars to get the gossip and bounties call
it deliver spinner and pick up side
quests from one of Enochs many eccentric
Denis's what exactly is your business
certain mercenary services it's hearty
showed us without spoilers but as you
progress through the game the world
state and NPC dialogue is affected by
pivotal norms from the story and new
side quests unlock some of which are
hidden in earlier ups in play spaces
further rewarding exploration combat
feats also come with achievements
complete a collectors quests like bounty
or monster hunt and NPCs will recognize
and reward your triumphs in bringing to
life a new sci-fi universe we are
adamant that Dee settle areas feel
dynamic and alive Oh in it monster hunts
piqued your interest stay tuned for a
future broadcast to learn more about
them well this should be interesting
crucially hops also allow you to check
in on your outriders trucking true which
will grow as he progress throughout the
game we're going to talk more about you
buy this truck in the future but his
primary function is to transport you
through the world bringing many of the
features of a town with it all the
functionality you'd expect from a hub
hits the road with you weapon vendor
your crafting your crew the truck is a
moving RPG village
now you don't operate the truck yourself
that job Falls to your driver Jakob who
we'll talk more about later but the
customization options are vast so you
can personalize your ride along your
journey okay let's pack up and hit the
road now I need to head to the forest to
continue my journey let's take a quick
moment to introduce the crew your rider
dies accompany you on your quest to
discover the source of the signal here
we can see Jakob who drives the truck
and can handle any customization of the
vehicle
Jakob buzz with your outrider during the
first arrival on enoch 30 years prior a
bright idea with an exciting life ahead
of him on a new planet time has not been
kind to poor Jakob here sahih d holy
metal last broadcast one of the few
people on enoch with a grasp on science
and how to get mankind out of the pickle
they happen to find themselves in you
can talk to sahih d4 weapon mods and
crafting we'll be talking more about
this topic in a next broadcast finally
at least for a moment here is Bailey who
has been appointed to your team by
Corrigan the grand marshal of trench
town who's allowed to travel through the
various sectors of the settlement let's
go Bailey hates the arrangement as much
as you do but is forced to join the
journey in camps like this Bailey also
acts as a gear vendor with a host of
unique weapons and armor you can trade
for scrap other notable features of a
given cam your stash
where you can store and withdraw
equipment that you might not be able to
hold on your person the stash also
allows you to move gear freely between
your roster of playable characters next
to the hammer here you'll always be able
to change and customize
of y'all driver and of course the
matchmaking terminal which is helpfully
self-explanatory before I'm leaving you
for this month's broadcast I'm going to
take you beyond the safe confines of the
Forester clave it's a beautiful night so
let's head out there and explore hey you
remember my tunes we used to play like
it was yesterday I can still remember
some of them please stop
yeah cool please I'm I'm serious yeah
Jakob I'm disconnecting
so that's your look at a journey hood
structure of outliners back to you Lucy
Thank You smen hopefully that gives you
a much better idea of the size and shape
of outriders and how your experience
with the game actually plays out all
right let's shift gears a bit here then
for another broadcast exclusive reveal
bringing the world of Enochs a life is a
chief bring more than just graphics and
story a big part of the atmosphere
you're soaked in whilst exploring and
surviving the hostile planet is achieved
through music we are very excited to
reveal that the outriders original
soundtrack has been composed and
arranged by none other than Anansi a
formidable name in the world of game
music with some huge titles and epic
scores under his belt in bringing the
sports a life enon joined a full
orchestra in budapest last year to lay
down the trucks for the game and we were
there to chat to him
[Music]
we came here today to TomTom studios
that the beautiful city of Budapest to
record the symphony of Budapest for the
project the outriders which is a whole
new game in the Olin franchise this is a
very unique experience for me I must say
with my knowledge in the orchestra the
way we basically crafted it combining
the orchestral sound with the electronic
sound and sometimes it is a lot of
editing sound these three elements
together is creating this I would say
soundscape specifically for this game
and we were able together create
something that is very unique ion is one
of the best composer and working the
game industry he's a very very busy man
everyone wants to work with him so was a
pleasure and honor for us event that he
decided to work with our company I'm
very intrigued by stories and this game
in particular has a very interesting
story and actually the story is what
drove the music to wherever it is this
orchestra is just I would say
[Music]
now their whole group of people that are
telling your story again and they're
adding their own voice and it just makes
the jobs such as pleasure
a game is a whole experience music is
there to be felt music is part of what
we're giving of the player as a
experience that he or she will go and
discover my best hope is that the music
will serve as you know the fourth they
mentioned the emotion that they
mentioned we want the player to really
be engaged in the game feeling the music
and not really noticing it it's there
it's supporting that's a thing is a
secret war
outriders was in many many ways an
extremely unique experience for me I am
so happy that I was able to work
together with people can fly and this
amazing project we took enough time to
develop our own idea of music and I
really like this kind of collaboration
and together we created a signature that
I really cannot wait the player to find
next up we're continuing our spotlight
series as we take a very detailed look
and various different aspects of the
game today it is the second of the games
fall classes the Pyromancer let's turn
up the heat
greetings outriders welcome to our
spotlight series a collection of videos
that delve deeper into specific aspects
of the game today we're taking a look at
our next class crank up the heat because
it's the pyro mansur as pyromancers
who is this class for players who like
to take on hordes of enemies at one also
pyromaniacs no just just kidding don't
actually set things on fire
during the game and set everything on
fire
paradoxes tend to fight at mid-range
they don't have the movement abilities
needed to get in and out of combat
quickly like their tricks the brethren
but many of their abilities are
area-of-effect based meaning you'll want
a decent amount of space to line them up
then light them up fundamentals the
Pyromancer has three core fundamentals
that underlies each of their powers
these are explosive immobilize and
ignite the Pyromancer is focused around
thermal and fire based powers and
effects which you can even see in the
classes melee attack
your standard melee attack will deal
fire damage to anyone it heads while
also inflicting extra effects as well it
is so much more than a skill just to use
in a raw panic healing even the best
combatants get injured from time to time
so knowing how to utilize your unique
paramater skills is essential to you
surviving as with all the classes there
are no quick fixes to retaining health
you need to play aggressively to restore
HP in the pyromancers case they can be
healed if an enemy dies while marked by
their skills any pyro mats are still
that damages an enemy will mark them for
a set time
this means that pyromancers can get
maximum healings and affects them the
greatest amount of enemies possible and
then also ensuring that those same
enemies meet a swift death powers each
class has eight powers in total starting
with a single power and unlocking more
as you level up many of the pyromancers
powers inflicts a stasis effects cause
burning
this sets enemies on fire and provides a
nice bit of damage over time however
inflicting burning also momentarily
stuns enemies and can be used as an
interrupt
that's enough general power information
let's check out four of the para Max's
abilities now power one thermal bomb
thermal bomb will set an enemy ablaze
and deal additional damage to them over
time if an enemy dies while under the
effects of thermal bomb they'll rise
into the air and explode in a gory mess
dealing damage to a large radius
combine this power with a mod of groups
enemies and the resulting explosion may
well wipe the rest of them out soon
you don't have to be the ones along the
killing blow either you can tag an enemy
and have the fellow outrider kill them
which will still trigger the thermal
bomb going up teamwork power to ash
blasts using this skill will apply the
state's effect ash to all enemies in a
large radius ash prevents affected
targets from doing anything at all for a
few seconds immobilizing luminous
suffocates in cloud of just a great
crowd control ability ash blasts can
cause large numbers of enemies to
briefly freeze in place this can be
combined really well with other powers
to hit a maximum number of enemies and
there are scenarios to use ash blasts
both offensively and defensively
offensive use ash blasts to prevent
enemies from escaping any area of effect
abilities you or your teammates might be
casting also natively ash blasts can
help you line enemies up for successful
headshot causing maximum damage defense
ash bots can force the bees to buy you
vital breathing room ironic seeing as
your foes will be choking
if you're being overwhelmed use it to
freeze enemies in their tracks and all
back to a more manageable distance power
three heatwave
this is one of the earliest powers you
unlock as the Pyromancer is a
medium-range class you'll want to
maintain a little bit of distance
between yourself and enemies and
heatwave is perfect for this if enemies
particularly in melee attackers try to
rush you heatwave will provide you with
the space you need to be most effective
at scolding them into crispy giblets
deep waves secondary effect shouldn't be
forgotten either the burn status effect
will deal damage over time to all
affected enemies which may well help
give you a nice burst of healing if they
feel the burn a little bit too literally
powerful overheat overheat may only deal
a small amount of damage to enemies
within a large radius but it does deal
extra damage to enemies that are
currently burning making it a great
follow-up skill
similarly it's a heatwave overheats is
an excellent way of marking numerous
foes and strategically setting yourself
up for a big burst of healing it's one
of those skills that just gets on with
everyone you know
it's synergizes really well with the
number of other powers to double down on
damage dealt the definition of
supportive we all need an overheat in
our life as we mentioned before our pyro
power will feature a further four powers
on top of those that we've shown today
but we will talk about these later down
the line power combos using powers by
themselves is all well and good but
utilizing them in combinations is where
outriders truly shines
heatwaves ability to hit several enemies
at once with burning means that overheat
can inflict maximum damage thermal bomb
on the other hand may only inflict
burning on through a single enemy at the
time but the state of effect still means
that overheat can be triggered to cause
extra damage ensure the thermal bomb
carrier dies and triggers the explosion
as mentioned the Pyromancer is ideally a
mid-range fighter who likes to keep
enemies at arm's length this combo will
show you how to do just that
while in battle heat wave neutralizes
enemies that gets you close following
heatwave up with ash blasts will ensure
that those enemies remain where they are
then place a thermal bomb amongst the
mob and focus all fire on that enemy if
you can kill them before the ash blast
effect wears off you can wreak havoc
with the thermal bomb explosion and bear
in mind these are only simple examples
of how powers could be changed you'll no
doubt find your own most effective ways
of playing out riders in your own style
also your Pyromancer each class has a
tree of class point nodes that you can
activate that also the way your build
and skills work class points are
acquired by leveling up you might be
able to fill out the entire class tree
but you will be able to respec your nose
to change the way you play the three
branches for the Pyromancer are ash
breaker firestorm and tempest with each
branch providing both major and minor
passives that affect your characters
type of damage focus and survivability
the ash breaker branch will generally
provide bonuses when dealing damage
against marked enemies while also
providing a boost in anomaly power the
firestorm branch is a path focused on
maximizing the damage outputs of skills
this path will allow you to increase
your anomaly power
you're burning damage and the still
damage you do are marked enemies the
tempest branch on the other hand helps
you fill more of its Hank role the path
focuses on maximizing your health bonus
and reducing the damage you take from
certain sources one of the more unique
passive bonuses you can activate on this
path is an automatic revival upon death
that's pretty handy
additionally the equipment you use may
impact the way your skills work the gear
you equip might reduce the cooldown or
duration of a skill or they make all
turrets on a more fundamental level but
fear not we will showcase these bad boys
in a future video and with that the
introduction to our Pyromancer is coming
to a close keep an eye out on our
YouTube channel for future gameplay
videos and other spotlights coming soon
subscribe and tip the notification bow
for videos that are hot off the press we
hope you got fired up exploring the
sizzling skills of the Pyromancer and
we'll see you next time
we are fast approaching the end of
broadcast - I know all good things must
come to an end but before we disappear
we're gonna continue our new tradition
of rounding things off with a bit of a Q
& A so earlier in the month we put a
call out for questions all across our
outriders social media channels if
you're not following us by the way you
should be and we gathered your burning
questions about the game and now we're
gonna answer them so Robby take it away
thanks Lucy and thanks to everyone for
sending in their questions be sure to
keep using the hashtag outriders on
social media let's jump into some
questions from the community this month
is there PvP the question of PvP is
asked a lot but right from the earliest
concept outriders has been designed as a
PvE game we're committed to making the
best single-player and co-op RPG shooter
out there
how long is outriders so it really
depends how you play the game you could
just do the main campaign by itself on a
single class and around 25 to 30 hours
but it will take two to three times that
long if you play all the side quests
post campaign and additional content in
outriders can we have multiple
characters or classes for the same
account if so do we need to repeat the
story every time to level them is Luke
bouncer a character or a class or can we
mail other things to another class
everyone will have access to up to six
character slots which you can fill with
whichever classes you desire you also
have a stash which can be used to share
items between characters is there any
sort of open world or open world areas
or is it just a hundred percent missions
although not open-world outriders
features a lot of open areas and
straying from the beaten path and
exploring the world of Enoch is a big
part of the game not only will you be
rewarded with gear opportunities to hunt
down special enemies and challenging
combat encounters but you'll also
uncover the mysteries of the
we we see or find out about beta endgame
cross-play and other features before
release all of these are big questions
that require big answers but you will
absolutely find out more about all of
them before launch we want to be open
honest and upfront about our game we're
not just trying to sell you the game on
just promises we're going to show you
exactly what you're going to get so make
sure you continue to tune in to future
broadcasts as we continue to unveil the
depth of outriders thanks again to
everyone that sent in their questions
keep using the hashtag outriders for the
chance to be featured in the outriders
broadcast 3 thank you for that Robbie we
will be putting a call up for questions
for the next broadcast very soon so make
sure you like subscribe followers on all
the social media channels and let us
know what you want to know because at
the end of the day that is what we're
here for we are here to answer your
questions I say we I mean just Robbie
and that is it that is outriders
broadcast 2 in the bag we hope you've
enjoyed what you've seen here today and
leave knowing just that much more about
the game big thanks for watching and we
will see you next time next time on the
outriders broadcast we'll be taking a
look at what it means to be altered
reborn with the planets energy flowing
through their veins outriders play an
important role in the broken war-torn
society of the new world we'll be taking
a look at the outriders journey from
something human to something much more
as we explore the brutal legendary Deus
Ex in the game modding and crafting gear
detailed look at the Devastator class
and much
the event
you
you